I uh really didn't expect to be
accepting this award on behalf of my
father's group The Beatles The Beatles
were fascinated with the Satanist
Alistar Crowley I mean they even had him
on their album cover along with a bunch
of other people that were interested in
the occult there's even some other
Crowley Easter eggs that you might not
have noticed before but why did they do
this let's uncover the truth another
thing that happened during the Grammys
that is kind of interesting is they made
an AI Beatles
song not necessarily that it was created
all by AI but they were awarded a Grammy
they cleaned it up was do you even know
who the to who the Beatles
are people on the screen right here I've
heard of them but that's yeah I've only
heard the name well it's interesting any
one of these award shows what happens
after them people are going to go home
and like start listening to it you get
get kind of back in the groove so to say
um The Beatles um you know this may seem
like super innocent music today but um
they had a song called now and then that
was really awarded um The Beatles I mean
these guys look super like innocent
compared to today's rock stars right oh
yeah for sure but this was some pretty
racy stuff back in the 60s and I think
there's a few things that we should keep
in mind about the Beatles um because you
know this was a very innocent time but
these guys like single-handedly began a
revolution using music and that was the
Catalyst that B basically began to
change a lot of people's lives and what
year was this like 70s ' 80s this about
the
60s yeah and these guys Rose to
incredible Fame in their life um what do
you think about their album covers
that's kind of Abby Road yeah Abby Road
um what do you think about this one well
that that one with the
yeah now in today's standards that looks
a little weird doesn't it it does look
weird it's like they went to the butcher
sh I think there's a reason why that
that this will make sense in just a
second Sergeant Pepper's Lonely Heart I
mean it seemed like their albums kind of
got a little bit weirder and weirder as
the drug World began to like kind of
spill out into the population right um
this was a supposed to be a concept um
thing they put Mr Alistar Crowley on the
cover here um who's Alistar Crowley you
guys know he's basically a Satanist yeah
is is he the one with the do what they
will yep y he wrote a couple books he
was a super old um in the turn of the
century like around the 1900s and um he
really is is is attributed to being the
wickedest man in our our kind of
lifetime so to say didn't his mom called
him the Beast or something like that
they did and his dad was a preacher
actually he was into some
crazy all kind of he went into some
pretty crazy things and he actually
wrote um some books about the occult
there's a lot of bands over the years
that have really been interested in him
um The Beatles that's why they put him
on the cover this is the opening line to
Sergeant Pepper it says in the first
song it was 20 years ago today Sergeant
Pepper taught the band to play and this
album came out 20 years after he died
and it's also interesting that it came
out around 20 years after this band
started yes so it's a really good
question of like who are you referring
to exactly and there's some very weird
things but Alistar Crowley was this
super super dark individual and there's
there's there's bands that have really
kind of um kind of thrown a lot like a a
back at Alistar Crowley Rolling Stones
is another one um the um um Black
Sabbath of course that's like probably
not a big shocker but he had a song
called Crowley um The Red Hot Chili
Peppers they were really big into their
um they have a a uh album called Magic
blood sugar magic which was taken after
ala Crowley's book
dude and that that's the crazy thing
because when you think about what he was
doing with this magic like this was him
practicing his magic incorporating all
kinds of vile things with children and
animals and and they're like yeah we're
clean boys but we're doing this on a
cover absolutely vile things in fact
Alistar Crowley had a place that he had
gotten a hold of in um Italy and he was
called The Abbey and in this building
right here they had all kind of Satanic
rituals
they would they would be into they would
be into it there was literally no rules
did you say this was from the Beatles
this place this is Al's place called The
ABY and here it is it's written on the
walls right here but this they had a lot
of oul practices that were done and
performed here and um evil evil stuff
that had happened in between these walls
Now isn't that kind of interesting that
they would call their album the Abby
Road well this is a real Road in the UK
though right there's a recording that
they actually go out there to take a
picture there and then also put him on
the cover and then look at this kind of
stuff I mean I think when you get into
this really dark
world you know people think of the
Beatles as this like innocent group but
these guys have have really put out some
pretty sick and disgusting things over
the years pretty fascinating that he
would title his book The Book of the law
because that's what the first five books
of the Old Testament are known as the
book of the law the Books of Moses the
Torah all kinds of different names but
it's known as the book of the law yeah
and he was quoted saying that the do
what thou Wilt is the whole of the law
so it's almost the exact opp Opposite of
what the Bible would say you know it's
like thinking of others right are are
they thinking of others right here
probably not I mean this is this is a a
definite like um dark thing but it's
interesting back in the 60s um when they
really started actually declining in
popularity um um watch this little clip
um this is actually what happened what
started people to question their
Morales The Beatles arrived in Japan
today as their tour of the Far East
continues across the Pacific in the
United States a furor is developing over
comments John Lennon made quote
Christianity will go it will vanish and
Shrink we're more popular than Jesus
unquote somebody was interviewing him in
the BBC and he's talking about England
in general and he's saying that we've
risen to a level of Fame that is
basically more relevant to people than
Jesus
ish and it didn't really catch a lot of
like flak in England except for when
American um journalists started to pick
up on this and they started writing
about it and it caused quite a stir yeah
and then his last line I don't know
which will go first rock and roll or
Christianity which they recognize that
they're not comptible by that statement
that they're against each other so to
add to what Keith is saying when you
understand the term rock and roll do you
guys know where this came from yeah it
was like the term about like yes it was
because kids teenagers were starting to
listen to this kind of music and while
listening to it we're having in the cars
and it started to rock and roll and
that's the reference to this music genre
now all has to do with and so he's just
like I don't know what's going to go
first Christian ity or rock and roll
he's clearly saying Christianity is
going to go we're going to take over
with this stuff the ' 60s was an
interesting time because you have this
this sort of rebellion that's happening
and they're they're coming off of having
these very sort of Leave it to Beaver
type you know home lives and they're
rebelling against that system and
against their parents and against God
and all that you know it's kind of all
together so um this is how the United
States actually reacted to it this is
time Charles if you as an American
Teenager are offended by statements from
a group of foreign singers which strike
at the very basis of our existence as
God-fearing patriotic citizens then we
urge you to take your Beetle records
pictures and souvenirs to the pickup
points about to be named and on the
night of the Beatles appearance in
Memphis August 19th they will be
destroyed in a huge public bonfire at a
place to be named soon stay tuned to
Wacky for further development so they
had big bombfire
dude very fascinating though if you take
a step
back this is also the time where the
United States is still probably reeling
from civil rights still dealing with
civil rights here they are throwing the
music away but at the same
time you know there's some other things
in Christianity we're dealing with that
were not that we not seeing as um you
know worthy of of fighting for yeah but
I think it's really cool though that in
a time of rebellion and uprisings and
stuff like that the people were actually
standing up for for their faith and
these are like young people burning you
know records I mean that's honestly I
think it's kind of cool when when do you
see you know Jen gen Z you're gen Z yeah
when do you see gen Z protesting in the
streets like we don't want this artist
they're
destroy didn't like uh save the planet
or or you know save the turtles or stuff
like that only electric cars we only do
it for the wrong reasons now yeah yeah
you know I think they're bringing up a
good point though with how should we be
treating some of these things it's like
you know should we be distancing
ourselves from the things that the world
is promoting as this is very popular but
it really has nothing to do with
Christianity living you know what I mean
the Bible's trying to get you to to live
as a Christian and so look at this verse
right here second Timothy 2:16 Keith
what does it say but avoid irreverent
Babble for it will lead people into more
and more
ungodliness there was a lot of Babble
that was that was thrown around with
them you know I mean did the arrogance
to say you know we're we're we're more
important than Jesus I mean that that
right there tells me that he does not
understand that the king of the universe
humbled himself and came down here just
just to save us mhm and it's like you
know these guys had never ever really
sat down and really considered what does
that mean I don't know if you noticed in
the very beginning John Lenin was
wearing a
cross I mean a lot of them do you know
what I mean like the early rock stars
that that that uh all wear crosses but
you know they have nothing to do with
Christianity just not only that there's
also like when he says Christianity will
probably go first I don't think he
realized that he was not the first one
attempting to do that you know for years
for that I mean we have the Dark Ages
which was probably the biggest event
movement in history to try to ban
Christianity before that there were the
Romans then there was you know the Dark
Ages with the Catholic church trying to
put their own version of Christianity
which we know it's not it was more um uh
the Beast putting its uh making its
power and then he comes along and he
doesn't have near as much influence as
those people right it was more out of
arrogance just like yeah we're going to
their parents were coming right off of
Elvis Presley I mean they actually went
through this like probably a decade
before that who identified as a
Christian as well but then was hugely
into the new age and use God's name in
vain all the time oh yeah you know and
you think about all this music is is
really just kind of putting these things
which if I remember right this is kind
of like a strange trivia I don't know
who owns it now but I think Michael
Jackson owned both the Beatles and Elvis
Presley's collection like he had rights
to those that's right I think that's
correct but I don't know who has it now
I mean with with Michael Jackson gone
maybe his kids yeah listen to this last
verse in 1 John
37-10 Little Children let no one deceive
you for whoever practices righteousness
is righteous I mean that makes perfect
sense right if you want to be righteous
you're going to want to practice that
right as he is righteous whoever makes
practice of sinning is of the devil and
the devil has been sinning from the
beginning the reason the Son of God
appeared was to destroy the works of the
devil all of these rebellious and these
self-centered ideas I mean thinking that
you are bigger than God that that really
originates with Lucifer I mean that that
single thought is actually really
Satan's first I want to be bigger than
God and here we see that being
perpetuated with the with the Beatles
right no one born of God makes a
practice of sinning for God's seed
abides in him and he cannot keep sinning
because he has been born of God by this
it is evident who are the children of
God and who are the children of the
devil it's it's pretty simple the
Bible's just laying it out there going
look you want to you want to follow
people you want to do things that are
going to to lead you into righteousness
practicing righteousness upholding holy
things those things are what the Bible's
wanting you to promote doing away with
the worldly kind of push and right now
we're seeing this weird blend of even
Christians basically becoming super
worldly mhm it's like they're
identifying as Christian but then
they're just anything but whoever does
um does not practice righteousness is
not of God nor the one who does not love
his brother I think if he truly loved
your brothers and sisters you wouldn't
want to do anything that would cause
someone's salvation to be forfeited
would you right right I think that's
what we see here I was talking to you
before about Katy Perry and the Super
Bowl and her performance and you know
it's really interesting when you see
all of these people just like in the
stadium watching her and then all these
people at home watching her all over the
world watching her and at the end she
gets lifted up on this star and just
paraded around the stadium and it's
really crazy that that's what being
offered to Jesus in Matthew 4 is hey
I'll give you the whole world just Bow
Down and Worship me and but you know now
they're being worshiped by the whole
world but it leads to death that's right
you know and and it's Jesus who changes
the heart who cleanses us from sin who
purifies us who the world sees as weak
but God sees as no they are actually
strong in me they have you know live
love not their lives unto death some
have died for their faith and I think
that's really the the the road for us
that we need to walk as Christians or if
even if if you're not believer yet to
try it out because this is not happiness
you know like this is not what's going
to bring life and joy and peace to
follow Satan to follow a guy named dast
Carley who is a Satan follower it's it's
God and you know we want to morph and
change our lives according to his laws
and his Commandments and his way of
living because that is the source of
life this just just brings death you can
see many people who have been held up to
this kind of standard over their
lifetime this seems to happen again and
again and again but we're we're a long
way from burning you know records The
Beatles think they have you know great
sales even now yeah you know it's the
thing of the past people don't think
that way anymore we're bringing them
back more than we're taking them exactly
I just want yeah yeah yeah we're just
putting people putting these guys in
front of everybody's Minds once again
but I think that you guys the Bible
constantly wants to push us to um put on
the robe of righteousness seek ye first
the kingdom of God and his righteousness
right that's what that's what Jesus is
really to do transform Our lives our
tastes our desires so that they're not
like just focused on these worldly
Ambitions and things so um hope you had
a blessing from this like and share this
video we'll see you guys on the next one
[Music]
a